hey this is presh talwalkar
the holderness family posted this math
problem for first grade students to
their facebook page
it is causing confusion and currently
being covered by major news outlets
in this video i want to explain what
many people believe to be the correct
answer
let me first read the problem
the picture shows some letters that are
arranged in a pattern
use the key to find the missing letter
the key is a conversion from letters to
numerical values
a is equal to 5
b is equal to 6 c is equal to 7 and so
on where each letter is equal to the
next number going all the way to z
equaling 30.
the picture is a three by three grid
that only involves the four corner
squares and the center square in the
first row
the two corner squares are question mark
and g
the second row is the center square b
and the third row is the corner squares
s and p
what is the value of the question mark
give it a try and now let me explain
what many people believe to be the
correct answer
we'll first convert the letters to
numerical values
g is equal to 11 b is equal to 6
s is equal to 23
and p is equal to 20.
what could the pattern be
many people see the pattern that the
numbers in the diagonal entries
should have the same numerical sum
this would lead to the equation 11 plus
6 plus 23 would be equal to question
mark plus 6 plus 20.
this means that 40 would be equal to
question mark plus 26 and therefore
question mark would be equal to 14
and that converts back
into the alphabetical value of j
so according to this pattern
the question mark should be equal to j
this is the main pattern that i saw and
many people saw
do you see any other patterns what do
you think the answer should be
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description